WE WILL SEE YOU TOMORROW.
♪ ♪
GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
ONE THING WE LEARNED ABOUT MASS
IMMIGRATION THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS IS THAT ALL GOOD PEOPLE
SUPPORTED.
IMMIGRATION IS THE ULTIMATE
MORAL LITMUS TEST.
THE DECENT AMONG US STEP FORWARD
TO WELCOME THEM IN.
THAT'S COMMANDED BY THE MORAL
CODE OF CABLE NEWS AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY, BY THE POEM AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE STATUE OF LIBERTY.
ONLY THE BIGOTS AND HATERS SLAM
THE DOOR, AS THEY'VE BEEN
TELLING US IN THE MEDIA NOW FOR
YEARS.
SEEING AS JIM ACOSTA HAS MADE
THAT POINT REPEATEDLY.
IT'S FINALLY HAPPENED, THE
CARAVAN HAS ARRIVED.
BUT HERE'S THE FUNNY PART, IT
DIDN'T ARRIVE IN OUR COUNTRY, IT
ARRIVED IN MEXICO IN THE BORDER
CITY OF TIJUANA.
THE PEOPLE OF TIJUANA OR MEXICAN
CITIZENS SO BY DEFINITION THEY
ARE GOOD PEOPLE COME UP MUCH
BETTER THAN YOU ARE.
THEY ARE MORE WELCOMING AND
COMPASSIONATE, LESS SELFISH AND
LESS AMERICAN.
THEY WILL GROW THE ECONOMY AND
ADD RICHMOND NEW DIVERSITY TO
THE CULTURE.
SO ARE THE PEOPLE OF TIJUANA
GRATEFUL FOR THIS CARAVAN FROM
HONDURAS?
FOX'S WILLIAM LA JEUNESSE WENT
THERE TO FIND OUT FIRSTHAND AND
HERE'S WHAT HE DISCOVERED.
>> SHOULD THIS CARAVAN HAVE BEEN
STOPPED AT THE GUATEMALA BORDER?
>> OF COURSE, I AGREE WITH THAT
100%.
YOU HAVE TO BE AWARE OF THESE
PEOPLE BECAUSE, THEY DON'T
BELONG HERE, THEY ARE JUST
MIGRANTS BUT IN THE SAME CASE,
IT'S LIKE MEXICAN MIGRANTS GOING
TO THE U.S. ARE UNDOCUMENTED.
>> DO YOU KNOW OF INCIDENCES
HERE IN TIJUANA AND OTHER CITIES
THAT SOME OF THESE PEOPLE THAT
ARE COMING INTO THESE CARAVANS
ARE COMMITTING CRIMES?
THIS IS NOT ABOUT RACISM.
WE DON'T DISLIKE A CERTAIN GROUP
OF PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY ARE FROM
ONE COUNTRY OR ANOTHER.
WE ARE HERE BECAUSE OUR
GOVERNMENT HAS NOT TAKEN CONTROL
OF THESE, WHAT WE CALL,
INVASIONS.
>> Tucker: WAIT A SECOND,
THAT'S NOT THE SCRIPT THAT WE
EXPECTED AT ALL.
THE MIGRANTS ARE DISRUPTIVE?
THEY "DON'T BELONG HERE?"
SOME OF THEM ARE CRIMINALS?
IT SOUNDS LIKE WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING IN TIJUANA IS, WHEN
HONDURAS SENDS ITS PEOPLE, THEY
ARE NOT SENDING THEIR BEST.
AND THAT'S A RACIST STATEMENT
BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP SAID
SOMETHING LIKE THAT IN MEXICO
ONCE AND THE GENIUSES ON CABLE
NEWS NEVER FORGOT IT AND ARE
STILL TALKING ABOUT THAT LINE
YEARS LATER.
AND YET, HERE YOU HAVE NONWHITE
PEOPLE SAYING EXACTLY THE SAME
THING.
LET'S CHECK BACK WITH TIJUANA TO
MAKE SURE WE HEARD THAT RIGHT.
[SPEAKING IN SPANISH]
>> Tucker: DONALD TRUMP WAS
RIGHT?
HOW COULD SOMEONE IN MEXICO SAY
THAT, EVERYONE IN MEXICO HATES
TRUMP BECAUSE HE BELIEVES AND
BORDERS.
NOBODY IN MEXICO BELIEVES AND
BORDERS, THEY ARE BETTER THAN
THAT.
MAYBE THAT WAS JUST A LONE
EXTREMIST TALKING, SOME CRAZY
PERSON WHO FOUND A MICROPHONE
AND A TV CAMERA.
WE BETTER CHECK WITH THE ELECTED
MAYOR OF TIJUANA BECAUSE IF
ANYONE CAN SPEAK FOR THE PEOPLE
OF THAT CITY, HE CAN.
HERE'S WHAT THE MAYOR HAD TO SAY
ABOUT THE MIGRANT CARAVAN.
>> [SPEAKING IN SPANISH]
>> Tucker: AN AVALANCHE?
A TSUNAMI?
NOTICE THE HUMANIZING TERMS HE
USES.
IF THIS WERE A LIBERAL ARTS
COLLEGE IN AMERICA THE MAYOR
COULD BE SUSPENDED FOR SAYING
THAT, HE DEFINITELY COULD BE IN
SOME KIND OF DIVERSITY
REEDUCATION CLASS BY NOW.
IF YOU WORKED AT GOOGLE, HE
WOULD BE FIRED INSTANTLY.
BUT HE'S NOT A STUDENT OR TECH
DRONE, HE'S THE MAYOR OF TIJUANA
AND PEOPLE CAN STILL SAY WHAT
THEY THINK WITHOUT FEAR OF BEING
DENOUNCED BY DON LAMONT ON CNN
AS A WHITE SUPREMACIST.
IN TIJUANA, WHAT THEY THINK IS
THAT A MASSIVE AND ABRUPT
DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGE IS A
DESTABILIZING TO A SOCIETY, NO
MATTER WHAT THE COLOR OF THE
PEOPLE INVOLVED MIGHT BE.
IT IS PARTICULARLY DESTABILIZING
IF YOU ARE NOT RICH AND MOST
PEOPLE IN TIJUANA ARE NOT.
EVEN IN MEXICO, THEY ARE WARY OF
IGNORING THE LAW COMPLETELY AND
TREATING BORDERS LIKE THEY DON'T
EXIST.
THEY KNOW THAT DOESN'T END WELL.
IN MEXICO THEY CAN SAY THAT OUT
LOUD.
HENRIQUE AZEVEDO WAS AN ANCHOR
AT UNIVISION WHO WAS JUST IN
TIJUANA AND HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
I'M CONFUSED.
WE JUST SAW A GROUP OF MEXICAN
CITIZENS IN TIJUANA SAYING
BASICALLY THE SAME THINGS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS ALMOST TO
THE WORD, ENDORSING TRUMP.
ARE THEY WHITE SUPREMACISTS?
>> YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
UNLIKE HUMAN BEINGS, INTOLERANC
INTOLERANCE, HATE AND EVEN
RACISTS FLOW FREELY ACROSS THE
BORDERS AND THAT IS WHAT YOU SAW
IN THOSE INTERVIEWS.
THEY ARE NOT RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES
EITHER.
THEY ARE PART OF A GROUP OF
AROUND 300 PROTESTERS IN A CITY
OF 1.3 MILLION WHO, LIKE MANY
OTHERS ARE ALONG THE WAY ARE
OPPOSED TO THAT IN TIJUANA, AND
THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE IN
TIJUANA WELCOME IMMIGRANTS.
IT'S A CITY OF --
>> Tucker: IS A BIG CITY FOR
SURE.
HOLD ON, YOU JUST SAID THAT THEY
ARE RACIST, BUT THEY ARE LATINO,
SPANISH-SPEAKING LATINOS,
ATTACKING OTHER SPANISH SPEAKING
AT LATINOS.
SO WHERE IS THE RACISM?
>> WE ARE NOT A MONOLITHIC
COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE PEOPLE FROM VENEZUELA,
COLOMBIA, DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS
AND INITIATIVES.
RACISM EXISTS IN MEXICO TOWARD
CENTRAL AMERICA.
WE WANT BUT HOW IS IT RACIST?
>> WHEN THEY GO ACROSS MEXICO,
VIOLENCE, EXTORTION AND RACISM.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW HOW
IT'S RACISM IF THEY APPEAR TO BE
THE SAME RACE.
BUT MOREOVER, AND I THINK I SAID
QUOTING ONE OF THE PROTESTS,
IT'S NOT ABOUT RACISM.
WE WANT OUR GOVERNMENTS TO
ENFORCE OUR BORDERS WHICH IS
WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE INCLUDING
ME STAY FREQUENTLY IN THE
UNITED STATES.
AS IT OCCURRED TO YOU THAT MAYBE
IT'S NOT JUST RACISM, MAYBE IT'S
OKAY TO WANT YOUR GOVERNMENT TO
KEEP YOUR BORDER INTACT?
>> I THINK WE SHOULD STOP
FRAMING THE IMMIGRATION DEBATE
ABOUT ABSOLUTES.
THE BORDER AS YOU SAW, IT'S IN
FOREST.
BORDER SECURITY THROUGH BORDER
PATROL, THROUGH MILITARY, AND
THROUGH THINGS LIKE DRONES AND
ATVs AND HIGH-TECH
SURVEILLANCE EQUIPMENT.
WE ARE ENFORCING THE BORDER.
THAT'S NOT A CRISIS OR INVASION,
THAT'S JUST A GROUP OF
IMMIGRANTS WANTING TO --
>> Tucker: I KNOW THE TALKING
POINTS, BUT WHAT IS SO
INTERESTING ABOUT THESE
INTERVIEWS AS THEY SEEM TO
CONTRADICT THE TALKING POINTS.
SO THE PEOPLE OF TIJUANA, WE
BOTH AGREE THEY ARE PROBABLY NOT
WHITE SUPREMACISTS, WE CAN TAKE
THAT AS A MATTER OF FAITH.
THEY SEEM TO THINK THIS IS A
CRISIS, AND IF THEY ARE CITY AND
THE MAYOR AGREES WITH THEM, AND
I ASSUME HE'S NOT A RACIST
EITHER, MAYBE HE IS.
>> I'M VERY FAMILIAR LAST WEEK.
AND HE DIDN'T MEAN ANY
DISCRIMINATION OR HARM.
IT THE MOST POLITICALLY CORRECT
MEDIA FIGURES ALSO, BUT BEFORE
WE GET HIM RETRACTING HIS
STATEMENTS FROM UNDER PRESSURE
FROM UNIVEST UNIVISION, DO YOU
THINK HE HAS ANY LEGITIMATE
COMPLAINTS?
AND OF COURSE AND GOVERNMENTS,
ALL THE GOVERNMENTS SHOULD
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS AND START
ACTING LIKE IT.
AGAIN, I'VE SAID THIS A THOUSAND
TIMES, WE CAN SPEND A LITTLE
MORE IN THE COUNTRIES WHERE
THESE PEOPLE ARE COMING FROM AND
MAKE A HUGE DIFFERENCE TO THE
BORDER.
>> Tucker: SO YOU FIGURED OUT,
WE'LL FIGURED OUT HOW TO FIX
HONDURAS AND MAKE IT SUCH A
THRIVING COUNTRY AND HOW WOULD
YOU DO THAT.
>> I'M NOT COMING UP WITH A NEW
IDEA.
WE JUST NEED MORE RESOURCES.
>> AND SO WHICH PROGRAM -- LET'S
GET SPECIFIC.
WHICH PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY WOULD
HAVE MADE THE ECONOMY OF
HONDURAS SO STRONG THAT NO ONE
WOULD WANT TO LEAVE AND COME TO
THE UNITED STATES?
>> SO USA FOR EXAMPLES WORKING
ON TWO OF THE COMMUNITIES WITH
THE HIGHEST MURDER RATE IN
HONDURAS.
THROUGHOUT THE LAST TWO OR THREE
YEARS, WITH THIS PROGRAM,
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO REDUCE
VIOLENCE AND THEREFORE REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE WHO WERE
LEAVING THAT TOWN.
THE ONE SO WHY DO WE HAVE A
CARAVAN OF HONDURANS COMING?
I HEAR THAT A LOT FROM DUMB
PEOPLE ON TELEVISION, I THINK
DON LAMONT SAID THAT ON CNN.
WE SHOULD SPEND MORE MONEY IN
THESE COUNTRIES.
HAS THERE EVER BEEN A PROGRAM
THAT CHANGE A COUNTRY IN THE
THIRD WORLD THAT MADE IT SO
APPEALING THAT NO ONE WANTED TO
COME TO THE UNITED STATES?
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A PROGRAM
LIKE THAT.
>> IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO HAVE A
PROGRAM FOR EVERYONE.
VIOLENCE IS A FACTOR, POVERTY IS
A FACTOR AND EVEN VIOLENCE.
WE HAVE A CARAVAN AND THEY WERE
TRACKING THEIR JOURNEY OF A
GROUP OF IMMIGRANTS FROM
HONDURAS WERE 90% OF CROPS HAVE
COLLAPSED.
THE CORRESPONDENT WAS TELLING ME
HOW THE GUATEMALAN REGION'S
FAMINE TO.
>> Tucker: I FEEL SORRY FOR
THE PEOPLE IN THE CARAVAN AND I
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY WANT TO COME
TO THE UNITED STATES, I LOVE
THIS COUNTRY.
I APPRECIATE THEIR GOOD TASTING
COUNTRIES.
BUT WHAT ABOUT EVERYBODY ELSE?
>> WE SHOULD START WORRYING WHEN
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO COME TO THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: THAT WILL HAPPEN
SOON IF THERE ISN'T A REAL
BORDER.
HONESTLY MY QUESTION IS, WHAT
ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THE
UNITED STATES OR IN THIS CASE
LIVE IN TIJUANA?
DO THEY HAVE ANY LEGITIMATE
REASON NOT TO WANT -- THEY DO
HAVE A LEGITIMATE REASON?
>> BY ALL MEANS OF COURSE.
WE DISCUSS THIS IN THE PAST.
I'VE LOOKED INTO IMMIGRATION AND
IT'S NOT A DESIRABLE OUTCOME FOR
ANY OF THESE PEOPLE.
BUT THE BETTER WAY IS MORE
HUMANE, COMPASSIONATE, AND
COMMON SENSE LAWS THAT WE CAN
HAVE INSTEAD OF WHAT WE ARE
DOING WITH TIMELY SEPARATION AND
MEASURES THAT DON'T MAKE ANY